do you remember the Tony Hawk's Pro
Skater series well someone's making a
documentary on those fantastic
skateboarding games and they're running
an IndieGoGo campaign to help them
finish up production
I'm Matt this is a GameSpot news update
and make sure to LIKE and subscribe
you're the first person to know all the
details about the bird band's next video
game the documentary is called
pretending I'm a Superman the Tony Hawk
video games story and it's being
produced by Ralph D'Amato who also
worked on the early Tony Hawk games I'd
prefer to see someone who wasn't
involved with the development make this
documentary but it'll be interesting to
see how D'Amato's personal experience
with the franchise will shape the
feature it's asking for a crowdfunding
amount of $75,000 on IndieGoGo GameSpot
did its own documentary style feature on
the Tony Hawk games a couple years ago
and it explored how the popular video
games influenced many to go from virtual
rails with the controller to the real
streets on an actual skateboard you can
watch it on our youtube channel right
now but if you want to shred on the
slopes of Hyrule check out our video
where we snowboard on shields and shoot
the Cobbins with arrows in Zelda breadth
of the wilds
Oh
[Music]